- [Instructor] Where we
left off in the last video,
the North had just won the Civil War.
Unfortunately for Abraham Lincoln,
it was two months after
he was assassinated.
But now the North was dominant
and essentially occupied the South.
And we enter a period
called Reconstruction,
and Reconstruction can
refer to one of two things
and they're somewhat related.
One is just the
Reconstruction from the war.
Obviously there was a lot of
damage done on both sides.
But it's usually referred
to the actual Reconstruction
of the South and to some degree,
kind of the reform of the South.
I'm going to glaze over a lot of details,
like I did in the last video.
I might ignore some major events
that you might find important.
And I'll get back to them, don't worry.
But the three big things
that happened during Reconstruction,
other than the fact of the
North occupying the South
and essentially, to a large degree,
suspending democracy in the South
and installing its own
politicians, its own lawmakers,
is that the United States passed
the 13th, 14th, and 15th Amendments.
These are known as the
Reconstruction Amendments.
In 1865, you have the 13th Amendment
and this abolished slavery.
Let me write this here.
This ended slavery.
We talked about the
Emancipation Proclamation
and that was essentially Abraham
Lincoln's executive order,
this was a speech he made.
But now it became official law in 1865.
Then in 1868, you have the 14th Amendment
which made everyone,
every person born in the
United States a citizen,
and this includes the freed slaves,
so it's kind of like,
the slaves are now free
and they are also citizens.
And then in 1870, you
have the 15th Amendment
which gave all free men the right to vote.
And obviously, now all men were free.
There were no non-free men.
So, the right to vote.
And I emphasize the men
because even at this point,
women did not have the right to vote.
The right to vote.
And the 14th Amendment also
introduced a due process which,
I won't go into the details
here, but it essentially said,
"Look, the government has
to go under a due process
"where it's subject to its
own laws when determining
"whether it can take away property from
"or in some way,
"infringe on rights of other people."
But we'll probably do a whole
video on that in the future.
But these were the real takeaways.
So it really brought the
former slaves, at least by law,
by these amendments, on equal standing.
But we know that in
practice, that didn't happen.
And you fast forward to
1877, and you essentially
have the Reconstruction
period formally ending.
The occupation of the South formally ends.
And as soon as the occupation
of the South formally ends,
and democracy comes
about, you have a bunch
of people coming to power.
And at this point of time,
the Republicans were
essentially the North,
and these were the people
who were anti-slavery.
Abraham Lincoln was a Republican.
And the Democrats come
to power in the South.
And we can talk about how
the different perceptions
of the different parties change over time.
But at this point, as soon
as the occupation ended,
and I put democracy in quotes
because even in this period,
the North has essentially
not occupied anymore,
but the elections, these were things
that were heavily contested.
You have both sides of
them exerting force.
And in particular, you
have the Jim Crow Laws
being passed in the South.
And they're called the Jim Crow based
on this parody in the early 1800s.
It was a practice for
white men in the South at this time,
or even well before this,
in order to parody blacks
they would paint their face black
and they would act silly and all of this.
And Jim Crow was the name
of one of these characters
that was portrayed in the early 1800s.
I think it was Jumping
Jim Crow, was the name.
That's where the laws come from.
But the Jim Crow Laws essentially
segregated blacks and whites in the South.
Even though the idea might
have been that they were equal,
the reality were that the
conditions for blacks,
the places that they were
separated to, were far inferior.
They had to use separate
drinking fountains,
they had to use separate bathrooms.
They couldn't sit in the
same parts of theaters
or in the same parts of buses.
And these lasted all the way until
the Civil Rights Movement,
all the way to the 1960s.
Now, at the same time that
all of this was happening,
you kinda had this post Civil
War boom in the economy,
where you had this massive building
of the railroads and steam engines.
To some degree, it was the first,
well, I don't wanna say the first.
There was many ages of mass innovation.
But all of these things
tend to always lead
to a little bit of a bubble.
And then in 1873, what
you have happening is
a lot of the governments of
the world start going off
of the gold and silver standard,
and they go to the gold standard.
And what then happens is,
is that anyone who's left
on the silver standard or partially both,
the gold and silver standard,
their currency would devalue.
And back then, it was viewed
as an unambiguous negative
for your currency to devalue.
We can later talk about that,
there's more nuance there.
So the United States
decide to follow suit.
And actually, the big
actor here was Germany
that decided to go off
of the silver standard
and going on pure gold standard.
And so the United States
decide to follow suit
with the Coinage Act in 1873.
But this leads to a huge, they
call it the Panic of 1873.
There's a couple of things here.
One, it completely demolishes
the price of silver,
although this was already
happening on a global basis.
It hurts the silver miners
and the industries associated
with the silver miners.
But I guess more importantly,
now this restricts the money supply.
And I won't go into all
of the economics of it.
When you restrict the money supply,
you essentially increase interest rates,
and it essentially popped
the bubble that was forming
due to the railroads and
all of the booming business.
And then you essentially have
the United States entering a depression.
And that depression lasts from 1873,
when the Coinage Act and
kind of this bubble burst,
all the way to 1879.
But lucky for the United
States, after that time period,
after it recovered from the depression,
it actually recovered
at this super fast rate,
and this was one of the
fastest economic growths
in US history.
You had this huge influx of immigrants,
tens of millions, from Europe.
And by 1890, the United States
was now the richest country
in the world on a per capita basis,
which is amazing because
only a hundred years ago,
it was kind of this
colony of Great Britain,
or part of the British Empire.
It was kind of this thing that
the European powers didn't
view as that relative.
But now it was the richest
country in the world.
And then you fast forward to 1898.
And it starts to, essentially,
become a bit of an empire.
Until this time, United
States kind of kept to itself.
It wasn't really interested
in controlling other
nations or other people.
But in 1898,
until 1898,
Cuba was a Spanish colony.
And there had been many revolts try
against the Spanish by the Cubans.
And the United States, or the Americans,
were fairly sympathetic to the Cubans.
After all, here's another
country in the New World,
again, trying to revolt
against a European power.
And the Spanish were pretty infamous
for cracking down pretty hard.
So in 1898, while there was
a revolt against the Spanish,
the United States set some
ships over to Havana Harbor,
essentially to protect American interests.
This might resonate a little bit relative
to maybe the Mexican-American War,
that we kind of send things
close to another country
to protect our interests
and make sure nothing crazy happens.
Then while in Savannah
Harbor, not Savannah,
while in Havana Harbor,
you have a battleship,
a US battleship called
the Maine, the Maine,
that explodes and sinks.
And this is an actual picture of it.
This is fun because we're
entering the point in history
where pictures start to become relevant.
Although, even in the mid
1860s, you had pictures.
That's a picture of Abraham Lincoln.
The Maine gets sunk.
The people who wanna
declare war on Spain say,
"Hey, Spain must've blown up the Maine."
Although it's still a complete mystery
on what was the actual cause.
Some people say it was
just a random explosion.
There's even conspiracy
theorists who believe
that the United States did
it to itself intentionally
to justify entering the
war, while some say,
"Hey, no. Spain did it
for whatever reason.
"It didn't like this American
fleet in Havana Harbor."
But regardless to say,
after this happened,
it allowed, it made the
American public angry,
the American government angry,
and they declared war on Spain.
And it was actually a
very short-lived war.
They won pretty handedly.
The big takeaway from
the Spanish-American War
is that the United States
essentially became an empire.
It started to have control
of other countries,
and in particular, it had
temporary control of Cuba.
But it also, because it
won, it got control of Guam,
which is right over there, and
it still has control of Guam.
It also got control of the
Philippines from Spain,
and it maintained control
of the Philippines
until the end of World War II.
And it got control of Puerto Rico,
which is still part of the United States.
It's not an official state
but it is United States territory.
So at this point, the United
States becomes an empire.
And then you fast forward to 1914.
War breaks out in Europe.
I need to do a whole series
of videos on World War I.
But war breaks out in Europe.
Particularly, the two strongest powers
that are really at each
other at this time period,
are the British Empire and Germany.
You have this situation
where United States
is trying its hardest to stay neutral.
Obviously, the American
people were predominantly
of English descent, it's an
English speaking country.
So there were some sympathies
for the British Empire,
for Great Britain.
But they wanted to stay neutral.
But what you had happening
is that the British
had a blockade of the Germans.
They really had a strangle hold.
And the Germans wanted to
have a blockade of the British
because Great Britain was an island.
It was an island, it could
really maybe win the war
if it could somehow strangle the island,
if it could blockade the island.
But unfortunately for Germany,
it did not have as strong of a navy.
So you get close to 1917,
actually 1915, 1916, 1917,
Germany starts to get desperate.
So it sends its submarines
into the Atlantic.
They say, "Well, if we can't
blockade Great Britain,
"at least maybe we can
start harassing ships
"or even blowing up ships that are trying
"to trade with Great Britain
and that'll make people
"afraid to, it'll
essentially be the equivalent
"of a blockade."
And at first, Germany
does some minor things.
But as the war goes on, it
gets more and more desperate.
It gets more and more desperate,
and it starts attacking
civilian ships, cruise liners,
Americans start dying
because German u-boats
are just willy-nilly, just
essentially torpedoing ships.
So the US doesn't tolerate it anymore,
enters the war in 1917.
Germany didn't take the
United States that seriously
up to that point.
But it learned, and we'll
do a whole series of videos
on this, that it should have.
And then you fast forward to 1918,
and the United States
was definitely one of,
the British were doing alright,
but the United States
really turned the tides.
No one really expected
how large of a power
they had essentially
gotten involved in the war.
Then you fast forward to
1918 and the war ends.
The real takeaway of this, I
mean there's a bunch of these
and we'll talk more about this
in depth in future videos,
is that it ended some of the nations
that were on the losing end.
Austria-Hungary no longer was a nation,
at least in this form.
The Ottoman Empire no longer
was a nation in this form.
And as we will learn later,
there were huge reparations
by the victors on Germany,
and that to a large degree,
may have led to World War II.
But we won't talk in depth
about that right now.
The other things that started
to happen at this point,
in 1920 you have the 18th
and the 19th Amendments being passed.
The 18th enacted Prohibition,
where all of a sudden,
you made alcohol illegal
in the United States.
And you know the irony of it is,
that's when you have all of these movies
about these bootleggers and
you have this whole crime scene
that develops around illegal alcohol.
But at the same time
the 19th Amendment was
maybe a little less controversial.
And the 19th Amendment, it finally gave
women the right to vote.
Right to vote.
And one of the arguments
against having women the right
to vote before this time was,
"Hey, you know, only men are
fighting for the country.
"Only they have the right to vote.
"Only they can be soldiers."
But during World War I, and this happened
not just in the US, this happened
worldwide in World War I,
that because so many men were fighting,
women really had to take
up the slack domestically.
And they, essentially, were
a big part of the war effort
in terms of just working at the factories
and producing things.
So that was probably one
of the big things that,
on kind of a global
basis, all of a sudden,
women started to get the right to vote.
Also, at this period,
you have in the 1920s,
you have another post-war economic boom
that really develops into
a post-war economic bubble
all the way until 1929.
And then you have the stock market crash,
and then I think some of us know that,
after that period, the
Great Depression ensues.
And the Great Depression continues.
And this was a global Great Depression,
and it continues all the way
to the US entry in World War II.
And I'll leave you there.